everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
starting our coverage of the 2017 u.s.
chess championships going to be going on
for a few weeks we have 12 competitors
in st. Louis Missouri
what's nice is three of the top six
players in the world are in this
tournament vying for the USA
championship number two in the world
right now is Wesley so third in the
world is Habanera Carmona who won this
event last year trying to repeat and in
sixth place in the world is Nakamura so
we're in for treat over the next few
weeks in round one today we're going to
be covering why it's going to be played
by Wesley so he is currently the highest
rated player in the United States he's
currently the second highest rated
player in the world and there's no one
that been better at chess lately than
Wesley so if you haven't been following
much in 2016 he won the grand chest tour
partly because he won both the Singh
field Cup and the London Classic just in
2017 one of the biggest tournaments of
the year the Tata Steel he won that
tournament edging out Magnus Carlsen the
current world champion so he is on fire
we're going to be watching him because
he's actually playing the lowest rated
player this is Alexander shovel off he's
49 years old so much older than 23
Wesley so but he's won the US
Championship four times before his most
recent one is in 2007 so it hasn't a
little while but he's very familiar with
this tournament and knows what it takes
to win what's nice about him is he's
kind of a wild card he plays really
really creative and he doesn't like to
draw at all and that's kind of the
players that I like to cover we're not
going to be getting into the 17 move
draw and move on to the next game or
coming out the gates sluggish this guy
likes to come out with fireworks and
Wesley so of being the top right player
definitely going to be a good match so
we'll go ahead and get into round 1 of
the US Chess Championships so it starts
out with pawn to c4 followed by pawn c6
well initially starts to look like the
English opening you can see it quickly
transitions in to the
gambits and specifically the slob
defense with this pawn c6 and d5
sometimes players will know that they're
going to be getting into the Queen's
Gambit lines so they just kind of take a
different approach to the starting
instead of your normal pawn to d4 and
then pawned c6 and then pawn c4 pawn d5
they chose to slightly change up the
opening but at the end of the day this
is getting into the slob defense and
this is the pure Slav with the bishop
coming outside at this pawn chain if you
were to get into the semi Slav you would
play pawn to e6 I personally prefer to
get the LightSquared Bishop out it does
get a little tricky if you block it off
with pawn to e6 more of a defensive way
to go
not really the aggressive line I would
expect from someone like Shabanov so
that's what we do see that the pure Slav
and then if you want to there's a few
ways to kind of attack this you can play
pawn to a6 early on you're kind of
expecting a pawn takes on d5 pawn
recapture and then you want to have a
pawn here on a6 to still protect the
square here on the 5 but now that you do
have the LightSquared Bishop outside the
pawn chain you can start to have a
little pressure on your opponent so
those are some of the things to keep in
mind in the pure sloth which Lisa starts
out with pawn to h3 kicking the bishop
back here to f5 and the Knight to c3
just developing as pieces like normal be
six and now here's kind of where I
thought we would see just a pawn take on
d5 nothing too crazy that's fairly
common on board you see the pawn takes
pawn recapture maybe Queen to b3 right
now trying to attack the center of the
board start adding pressure on your
opponent you don't want them to play
that pawn to a6 right away since you are
threatening Queen takes on b7 so you
could say Queen to c7 and then Bishop to
e2 getting ready to castle on the King
side the Wesley so decides to go for
something different he says you know
first game we're not going to be playing
passive at all play pawn to g4 and this
is an aggressive take usually when
you're playing the Queen's Gambit
pushing up pawn to d4
and c4 usually means you're not going to
be castling on the queenside because you
just don't have a lot of protection for
your king your pawns are pushed to four
there's too much air in front of your
King the pawn to d4 says stuff's going
to have stuff is going to happen in this
game I'm going to play pretty aggressive
here so the bishop comes back to g6 it's
worse if you were to come to e4 just
gets tricky then pawn pushes forward to
g5 attacking the knight if the bishop
takes Queen recaptures now Knight down
here to e4 he could come back here to g8
but then that's just kind of kind of
ugly for black since he's just wasting
his moves coming back to the
eighth-ranked and he has no pieces
beyond the eighth-ranked right here so
nice to e4 and then after capture pawn
takes Queen takes here on e4 white is
just completely dominating the board as
far as material and tempo and black is
going to have a hard time getting back
in this game Wesley so I think we'll
just kind of overwhelm his opponent so
in the game decides to bring his vision
back here to g6 and the knight up here
to e5 if you are going to be playing
this pawn to g4 you have to continue to
be aggressive in your game wesayso can't
just stay back and then develop his
pieces bishop here to e2 and try to see
what he wants to do with this King he
needs continued ibly as aggressive as
possible the bishop really can't go
anywhere right now so he knows his
bishops going to fall he decides going
to play Knight to d7 start to add some
other pieces on to his defense on the
King side of the board and also kind of
make sure that this night is going to do
something he can't just sit here all day
because the knight is threatening the
square here on e5 so decides to go ahead
and take here on a g6 takes back with
his H pawn this does open up the door
for a semi open file for this rook here
for h8 so this is another reason why
we're probably not going to be seeing
Wesley so castle on the King side
because he is very vulnerable for an
attack with this rook here on h8 whiskey
so now decides to continue to push
forward pawn here to g5 forcing the
knight to move and the knight has a
couple options he decides to go ahead
and play Knight back here to GA
eight if he wanted to he could bring the
night down here to e4 then we're just
going to see capture after this capture
pawn up here to h4 and I think all in
all why it's going to have a better
position there's double pawns here on
the G file that's double pawns here on
the e-file it's going to be difficult
for black to really hold on to this all
this material in the center of the board
so I think this would be better off for
white so although I don't necessarily
like a black bring is nice back here to
g8 because it is somewhat of a waste to
move it's going to be more difficult to
get this Knight really involved into the
action I do think it is better than
bringing it down here to e4 what
continues with pawn to age four and then
Knight to e7 the knight has to get back
involved into the game it can't come
here to f6 or a six because of this pond
nicely placed so ii 7 is kind of an
obvious move for black here then a
bishop here to d2 not sure i expected to
see bishop here to d2 but instead we
might see palm pushing forward to h5
just putting more pressure on his
opponent you know h5 the rook takes
maybe the rook takes here on h5 pawn
recaptures queen takes up here on hbox
starts to add more pressure on the Kings
side of the board usually going to be
seeing a black castle on the Queen side
but then it's just kind of fireworks
because Wesley so can just start to come
behind enemy lines and start to add more
pressure on his opponent paneer to g6
and then the Queen back here to g4 in
the game we decided to seize somewhat of
an interesting move Bishop here to d2
making it look like he's going to start
to castle on the King side or the Queen
side Knight to f5 getting it involved
into the action as we talked about a
nice little outpost move for this Knight
right here and then Queen up here to g4
just attacking this night and also
controlling the sin of the board also
does open up for this King to castle on
the Queen side now from here we see pawn
to a6 and I'm not sure pond a6 is the
right way to think about this from black
yes you want to be playing pawn to e6
early in this
of defense when you think there may be
an exchange in the center specifically
on that this d5 square but that's not
really what the game is about right now
you don't want to be playing too passive
right now this is sort of a defensive
move trying to see where your opponent's
going to be going making sure it doesn't
bring his knight here to b5 making sure
it doesn't bring this light square
bishop over here to b5 after this pawn
here on c4 is moved but right now the
game is about this King coming over here
castling on the Queen side and just
throwing as much as you can on the Queen
side of the board not really looking at
this pawn to a6 but that's we decides to
do I think I would have preferred just
playing Bishop here to e7 just getting
involved into the action this does
prevent your opponent from castling on
the Queen side because you could just
now take with your Bishop on c5 you
can't recapture with this pawn because
then the rook comes down captures on h1
so that's bad so it does stop them from
doing what they want to do
I don't think a six really stops what so
from doing wants to do he does castle on
the Queen side as we talked about pawn
captures here on c4 and the bishop comes
up here and takes on d4 and the next
move somewhat interesting as far as what
black wants to do he has a few different
pieces he can get involved into the
action and can bring his bishop here to
b4 he could bring his knight here to b6
this opens up some opportunities it
attacks the bishop right here also opens
up the door for his queen to get
involved into the action he could bring
his queen involvement it actually could
bring it Queen here to c7 does allow him
to castle on the Queen side does allow
him to get his rook on this D file
semi-open foul to start to attack I
think he somewhat needs to have some of
these pawns in front he has so much
pressure on the King side of the board
usually when your opponent castles on
the Queen side like Wesley so does he
can just throw the kitchen sink on the
Kings side so black is not going to be
looking to castle on the Kings side too
much he doesn't have a great defense
here with no pawn on the h-file and then
knowing that Wesley so can just start
pushing up the board he already has his
queen is rook over here it's gonna be
looking on the Queen side I was
interested to see this next move because
he didn't really do any
of those that we talked about I thought
the best move right here would be Knight
to b6 because it doesn't tack and opens
up the door for the Queen ain't I'm some
of your normal moves through a couple
things on board I really like that
approach even just getting your
dark-squared bishop involved more
aggressive on the Queen side the board I
think makes sense he decided to go and
play pawn to c5 which kind of blows up
the center of the board it's not
necessarily a bad move but it's a very
risky move because after the pawn takes
the bishop takes this is a good square
for this Bishop but all of a sudden we
start to see some open files on the
Queen side of the board there's no
longer a safe passage for the black King
we are talking about it's not going to
be looking to castle on the Kings side I
think it's now risky to castle on the
Queen side and so this is where we start
to see a little bit of black being that
risky player knowing that he's up
getting someone much stronger than him
who's just going to put Wesley so in
some really tough decisions and say hey
do you have the chops here because I'm
going to be as aggressive as I possibly
can and just see if you can make a
mistake why continues with Bishop back
here to e2 and then the big bishop comes
back here to e7 kind of opening up the
door for these long files to start to be
taken advantage of by some of the
stronger pieces on board so decides to
bring is a king over here to be one
wants to make sure that this King is not
in line for a strong attack with the
rook coming over here to c8 once they
have it protected behind some of these
pawns right here I snap expected black
the not even think about this too much
to play rook over here to c8 hopefully a
lot of you look at this and recognize
that rook to see it makes a lot of sense
you want to get your books involved into
the action if they can control an open
file that's where they belong especially
if that's where your opponent's king is
situated I think he has some really
strong attack simply plays realcare to
c8 that's not what he decided to do and
say decide to play rook here to b6 not
sure that's what the game is about and
then we see Knight to a4 I like the
aggressive play from Wesley so always
putting his opponent in a position
where he's going to force two to move
and play defenses instead of coming up
with a more aggressive line like I know
black wants to be doing in this position
also think pawn to e4 would have been
fine as well brings the knight back here
to d6 and then Bishop e3 just more
centralizing the bishop attacking the
Queen right here but all in all I still
like his approach with Knight to a4 now
the Queen comes back here to c7 rook
here to see one and then Queen out here
to d6 but you can see how different this
is for white white now controls this C
file right here and then all of a sudden
this rook on a eight doesn't look that
great anymore can't really bring it to
see a dry down it would fall and so it
just kind of sits there and just kind of
wonders what's going to be happening
from Wesley so Bishop here to a5 so you
can see starting to put a lot of
pressure on his opponent doesn't have
many great moves I still think it's very
dangerous from the castle on and the
King side and but he's just kind of
taking away any of the squares on the
Queen side of the board so it's king
somewhat trapped in the center of the
board definitely not what you want to be
doing in a chess game night here to e5
Queen over here to e4 putting more
pressure attacking this pawn here on b7
men up here to c6
I think this somewhat misses the boat it
is trying to stop a lot of the pressure
on board but really just playing to
defensive in my opinion rook over here
to d1 attacking the Queen Queen is
forced to move or have this in between
move rook down here to h4 attacking the
Queen
but then pawn to f4 pretty much puts a
stop to that that only does it put a
stop to it solidifies this pawn chain
but it now completely takes away any
potential to castle on the kingside
swing the rook over get involved on the
Queen side of the board this work on h4
is now completely away from any of the
action that's going on while Wesley so
if you look at it he has all of his
material kind of cohesively working
together on the Queen side of the board
Queen back here to b8 this is another
one of those where
I just don't necessarily like my queen
coming back here to be a if you're this
in this position on the board we remove
24 and your rook is on a 8 and your
queen is on d8 this is not the position
you want to be in this kind of the the
surrender Cobra and in a sports arena
where you just kind of look at me like
yeah he's somewhat given up you're just
kind of trying to hold on as much as
possible but things are not looking good
Wesley so recognizes this and he starts
to just be more aggressive Knight here
to b6 attacking the rook you almost
expect the rook to have to come here to
a7 it is trapped right now that there's
really no where else to go
but he doesn't he plays Knight to d6
attacking the Queen but it just doesn't
do enough the Queen can now come here to
a4 and things just get really really
difficult it does now pin down the
knight to the king and so there's just
no longer any great moves rook to a7 now
but you can see black she's playing
completely defensive neither of his
rooks are doing anything on board we
always talk about what material is
involved in the action black doesn't
really have any material these Knights
are just kind of blocking some of the
attacks off but they're not doing
anything productive Bishop here to f3
starting to add more attacks on this
central square here on c6 in the stern
of the board Knight to b5 trying to
block off some of the attacks because he
does have this outpost from the pawn
here on a6 but then Queen down here c3
making sure he still can attack the
square here on c6 Queen to c7 there's
just not a lot of moves for this Queen
to come to we can't come to these six it
would fall from the rook can't come here
to e5 cut the pawn there's just no great
squares in both 8 and c8 are both being
attacked by night here on b6
but after the word comes here to c7 then
you have Knight to d7 and black is
forced to resign there's just no great
squares for black to go to right now
many times people ask well how would
this continue on board so we can look at
a few
examples of what it might look like
let's say the Queen came back here to b8
one of the few safe moves for the Queen
then all of a sudden Bishop takes here
on c6 you know there is going to be a
discovered attack after the rook moves
here so maybe the King moves then the
bishop takes back here on b5 on all the
pieces just start to crumble nothing
good is going on in this position if we
could come back and say what if the
Queen just takes here on d7 then the
Queen's going to fall that's sort of the
obvious one Bishop down here d6 Knight
to e5 nice little outpost but just kind
of just sets it up for bad things to
happen Bishop takes here on c6 pawn
recapture is cling up here to c6 if
instead we come back and then the King
comes to f8 well same thing that the
queen is going to fall right here so
although there's not much that black can
do here he recognizes that he kind of
dug himself in a hole all of his pieces
are just kind of congested right here
what's this oh just going to start
picking them off so decides to go ahead
and resign love the fact that he gave a
great effort he played the most
aggressive lunge you could in most of
the positions I think a few different
places he could have definitely played
better but all in all Wesley so came out
the gates with that pawn to g4 played
extremely aggressive and said hey I
cannot come away from this game playing
the lowest rated player at this
tournament and not come away with a win
with the white pieces and he does what
he's been doing for the last year and he
just kind of took advantage in won the
game so congratulations to him the
hottest player coming into the
tournament definitely the favorite right
now in the field so all in all great
round one usually in these tournaments
we see some sluggish starts some drawls
for the first few rounds we try to
figure out winds are going to be some
exciting chests we got one in round one
so hope you guys are excited about this
tournament got a few weeks of great
chess but thanks for watching I'll see
you in round 2